I crave pasta multiple times a week,
and since I couldn't make it at home,
the next best place to get it is Milan, Italy.
So today we went to this cute Italian restaurant,
and my eyes immediately zeroed in on the pizza and pasta.
So I knew exactly what pasta I wanted to order,
but I let the boys figure out the rest.
I brought out some bread, which was kind of stale,
so I didn't have a lot of it.
Got a salad. We got two different pastas.
One of them was carbonara.
The other one was this papa del.
We got Diavolo pizza,
and I just started digging in since I was starving.
Carbonara was so good. It was just too creamy for me.
This mushroom parmigiana was so good,
and I kept having it. Everything just needed a little bit of salt.
The pizza was absolutely perfect.
The boys loved that the most alongside the steak.
Lucky didn't like the carbonara,
so I had his. He was still hungry,
so he got himself another pizza,
and I wanted another portion of the parpedal.
Lucky loves the combination of balsamic and pizza,
which I'm not too sure about this point.
I was done. Lucky finished off my pasta.
I was stuffed, but needed something sweet,
so I had some gelato, and we headed home.